Alright guys,
This is going to be a very interesting video.
You know, when Noah and his family stepped off
the ark, what was the world like, just imagine.
What was the world like for them,
and for the generations after them.
How did they survive in this new world?
And start civilizations?
And why did it becomes so
evil at the Tower of Babel?
And then, what about the animals -
did they really come from the ark?
And what about the dinosaurs, or dragons,
because we know that the word dinosaur
did not exist back then.
Well, let's get into this
interesting and amazing video.
Let's go back into the past.
Alright,
now in the previous video, we talked
about how brutal and evil the world was
in the time before the flood.
In the antediluvian period,
when the fallen angels came down.
When the Nephilim started to walk the earth.
And, men who only thought evil continually until
God had to step in and stop it all with the flood.
But then, we see the same thing
happening again after the flood.
People became more and more evil
at the Tower of Babel, especially.
Why?
Did some of the ancient knowledge somehow
survive the flood, teaching people to
worship other gods, AKA fallen angels?
And how to use evil crops and so forth?
Because we do know that the people after the
flood had some sort of ancient knowledge.
Secret sciences.
They even knew how to practice magic some
ancient writings called the seven sacred sciences,
which people perverted and used for evil.
Some of this knowledge was just about basic
things like building buildings - masonry- we
know the Babylonians, Acadians and Assyrians
and other nations continued to build amazing
buildings like ziggurats and might even have
repaired some of the pre-flood ziggurats and
kept these legends or cultures alive.
Now, for those of you who know about the
Freemasons, it is interesting that the Freemasons
believe that the ancient corrupted sciences - the
knowledge - first moved from Babylon and Syria
to Egypt - and I mentioned two possible ways
of how that could have happened - but I don't
have time to delve into that completely now.
It is interesting, though, that the Bible does
talk about corrupted sciences or knowledge.
It doesn't call it by its name, but
we see that there were certain people
who practiced strange things, like magic.
Do you remember the evil sorceress in Egypt?
[Exodus 7:11]
Why were these men called "wise"?
They knew certain things.
And also the sorcerers.
So the Bible does mention secret arts.
[Exodus 7:12]
Now, in the past, people who rebelled against
God used knowledge - secret knowledge - for evil.
People also used knowledge for good.
But these people use the knowledge - they
perverted it - especially in a time
when the fallen angels came to earth.
And we know that a lot of people followed
demons - teachings of demons - and so
they've gained these secret arts or the
knowledge of these secret arts to do evil.
Many ancient writings actually say that
the fallen angels - when they came down
to sleep with the woman of earth to create
the nephilim - that they also gave secret
knowledge - craft - arts - to people to teach them
so that they can be lured away and not obey God.
But that they now serve these demons as
gods and we even see it after the flood.
How astronomy was perverted to astrology and
was associated with magicians, sorcerers,
Chaldeans, or the Magi even in the time of Jesus.
These kind of people were around.
These wise men - these Magi - because of the star.
They knew about Jesus.
[Matthew 2:1-2 ]
So, is this part of the reason why the
earth became so evil again after the flood?
Shortly after the flood at the
Tower of Babel, because of this
secret perverted ancient knowledge?
And if it is part of the reason,
where did they get the knowledge from?
That some of this ancient knowledge
somehow survive the flood on stone tablets?
Did one of Noah's children or children's
children pervert the good knowledge of
Noah which he received from his family
line all the way from Adam, who, of course
spent time with God Himself in the garden?
Or what happened?
And after the flood, think about all the other
things as well - what was the world really like?
The animals - did all the animals
greatly repopulate the Earth?
What about the dinosaurs or called
dragons before 1841?
So many questions.
Alright, so let's start at the beginning.
First, let's focus on Noah.
Before the flood, he was the
10th generation from Adam.
According to Genesis 5:
Ten generations.
And there was something special
about Noah that you might not know.
God had a plan for Noah.
Even his name - Noah - meant something special.
[Genesis 5:28-29]
So Lamech had knowledge about Noah
that we don't because of his name and
because of what he said his name means
- that he will bring relief for them.
Now, Noah might have also looked different.
That might have been part of the reason why
Lamech said this or called him Noah.
I'm not 100 percent sure here.
But one of the Apocrypha books does
describe Noah, which is very interesting.
The book of Enoch says this about his description:
The flesh, of which was white as snow, and red as
a rose. The hair, of whose head was white like
wool. And long. And whose eyes were beautiful.
When he opened them, he illuminated
all the house. Like the sun.
Interesting, isn't it?
But please know and understand
every time when I quote from something that is
not part of the Bible, like the Apocrypha and what
other ancient writers said, it is interesting
what they said, and it could have been true.
But we're not 100 percent sure.
You can, however, trust the Bible,
which has been inspired by God and
is the only absolute truth we have.
[2 Timothy 3:16-17]
Now you know the meaning of Noah.
But did you know that if you take
the names of Adam, Seth, and the whole line until
Noah, each of them, their names, mean something.
And if you put it together it makes a sentence.
And that sentence is a prophecy about the
Messiah Jesus Christ.
Take a look at this.
Adam means man.
Seth means appointed.
Enosh mortal.
Keenan sorrow.
Mahalalel the blessed one.
Jared shall come down.
Enoch teaching.
Methuselah - his death shall bring
Lamech - the despairing
Noah - rest or comfort.
Now read it with me altogether.
The man appointed mortal sorrow.
This shows the fall of humankind of man.
That sin entered the world.
The Blessed One shall come down teaching.
This is Jesus, coming down to teach us the truth,
His death shall bring the
despairing rest and comfort.
And that's exactly what Jesus came to do.
To come and make us free,
so that we can enter His eternal rest.
You see, before Jesus came, people tried to
obey the law just from their own will, right?
Their own soul.
They couldn't.
Time after time after time.
Sin just took over.
Because of the sinful nature that is within us.
But then Jesus came to die
for our sin on the cross.
And now, those who look to Him, who believe in
Jesus Christ as Lord and Savior, will be saved.
So now God the Father, when He
judges us, He looks through Jesus.
What He did for us on the cross.
And He declares us as righteous,
but not only that - if we accept
Him - He comes to live inside of us.
He makes us a new creation.
We become spiritually alive and we have now the
ability to have a relationship with God again.
The same way that Adam had before
sin came into the world.
We still have that fleshly nature but
now we also have the new spiritual nature in us.
And the Bible says that we can only worship God in
spirit and in truth, because God is Spirit.
But alright, let's go back to Noah.
In Genesis Chapter 7, God gave Noah
specific instructions to build an ark.
And this is what happened.
[Genesis 7:11]
So the water did not just come from the heavens
- from the clouds - it burst through the earth.
And it's very interesting that recently they
discovered a huge ocean near the earth's core.
And Stephen Jacobson from Northwestern
University in Evanston, Illinois,
says it's good evidence the
earth's water came from within.
He's right.
The post-flood world, the
world that we live in now, has a lot more water
on the surface compared to the antediluvian world.
[Genesis 7:13-14]
I'll tell you in a few
minutes why this is important.
According to its kind.
So all the animals that lived before the
flood in the antediluvian period - they
didn't all just go on the ark.
The Bible says two of every kind.
And it says that four times in Verse 14 for a
reason, so that we can hear and understand, so
after hundreds of years you
will have different types,
but it's the same kind.
For example,
we get different types of horses today but
they are still horses, not something else.
We also get many types of dogs but
they are still dogs, not cats or mice.
So was it possible to fit them all on the ark.
All the different kinds of animals and beasts.
Two of every kind.
What about the dinosaurs or
back then called the dragons.
Well, I answered the same question
on my other channel, so check it out.
So every animal of its kind.
That includes dinosaurs.
Now you might say, Daniel,
that's just... that's just crazy.
Dinosaurs are huge.
So there's no way that
huge dinosaurs could have been brought on the
ark with all of the other animals as well.
That might be true - not huge dinosaurs
and huge animals - but babies definitely.
It will be much easier and wiser to take small
animals into the ark and not big and old ones,
so that after the flood they could have
lived longer and produce more babies.
Big dinosaurs were big.
Well, some of them,
depending on their kind, right?
But the babies were, well, babies.
Small.
Do you know what the biggest
egg fossil is that they found of dinosaurs?
The biggest dinosaur egg fossil was around
the size of a football. That's it.
That's close to an ostrich egg.
So imagine the size of a dinosaur that could
come out of that egg. Not very big, right?
And then before the flood they had
hundreds of years to grow, right?
Remember lizards, they never stop growing, and so
they have hundreds of years to grow because that's
how all the people got at that time as well.
Very, very old.
Some over 900 years old.
And the Ark was a lot bigger than people think.
The Ark Encounter in northern Kentucky shows us
they created the ark replica according
to the instructions of the Bible.
And so doing proved that it was possible to
bring so many different animals on the ark.
Take some time and go visit
them, when you have the chance.
Alright now, if you want to watch the rest of
that video and also part two where I explain how
the dinosaurs became extinct - dragons - then you
can hop on to my other channel after this video.
I'll add it to your new video description so
you can check it out. Now, how was it possible
for the humans to repopulate again?
Noah and his family were not cavemen.
Dumb and looked like apes.
They were intelligent humans who did not start
over from scratch not knowing how to build houses.
I mean they learned how to build the ark.
Put yourself in their shoes.
You would have prepared for this new world
so I believe that Noah and his family prepared.
They brought all the knowledge and skills - the
things that they needed - with them
on the ark including the memories,
knowing where people from the pre-flood
world - the antediluvian world - lived.
So, over time, they could have checked out these
places to see what is left after the flood.
And even repaired some of it if it was possible.
And God didn't just leave them and say alright,
go and try to repopulate the earth.
He actually blessed them to repopulate the earth.
[Genesis 9:1]
So they did but sadly the world became evil again.
Why?
Well, Noah had only three sons.
He had Shem, Ham and Japheth.
Now Abraham and the Nation
of Israel came from Shem.
And I believe most of the evil
people came from the line of Ham.
His children were Cush, Egypt, Put,
and Canaan according to Genesis 10.
Now I know this video is long, but
this is important, so please focus.
Listen up.
So Ham had Cush and Cush had Nimrod.
You would remember Nimrod from my previous videos.
He was the first world leader in a sense who built
many cities and something else as well
which is very interesting - the Tower
of Babel was built through him and it
was built in rebellion against God.
[Genesis 10:8-10]
In a sense this almost feels like a
fantasy story like the Lord of Rings
because it talks about the Land of Shinar.
There's a lot of ideas that Hollywood
takes from the Bible.
If you just focus.
Verse 11 says:
[Genesis 10:11-12]
Now, this is where it gets very interesting
and the Bible doesn't give us a lot of
information of why it got so evil again.
It gave us just a bit of information so that
we can understand how people spread throughout the
world and how Abraham came into the world - how
his son started the Nation of Israel.
And how the Messiah of prophecy came
because that's what the Bible is all about -
about Jesus - the Old Testament and the new.
Now I believe it got so evil
because human beings are evil.
We have a sinful nature within us
and if we don't want to worship
God - the light - then we move into darkness.
And as generations go on, it becomes more evil.
But it became, in a sense, it was accelerated.
They were put on the fast track because of
the devil and his demons who gave them the
same ancient corrupted knowledge that they
made available through the fallen
angels to humans before the flood.
There is a spiritual world that we cannot see
and the devil and his demons - they've always
influenced human beings - but it will become
more clear to you as we continue in this video.
Let's read Genesis 11 verse 1.
[Genesis 11:1-2]
Now you remember in the previous verse,
it said that the Land of Shinar is the
kingdom that Nimrod started, like Babel.
[Genesis 11:3]
This shows us again that they
were advanced civilizations
having the knowledge to build amazing buildings.
[Genesis 11:4]
Lest we be dispersed over
the face of the whole earth.
Remember, the flood came so
that was the judgment of God.
Now again, they don't want to be judged
by God if they continue in their own ways,
in their sin, so they want to build a place
for themselves reaching to the heavens
and build this tower in rebellion against God.
I'll explain this a little bit further on.
Now, the Bible doesn't talk about
the ancient knowledge that they
had apart from what they built, right?
The effects of the knowledge - so they
had to have the knowledge to be able to build
these amazing cities and also the Tower of Babel.
So we know that they have they had
masonry skills but other ancient writings
explain a little bit more.
Some call it the seven sacred sciences,
which include geometry and astronomy.
According to some, there was a pure branch
of knowledge and an evil branch of knowledge.
There was always this fight between good and evil.
And even if we go back before the flood - back
back back back back to the Garden of Eden
- there was the tree of good and evil.
[Genesis 2:17]
And then, you know the rest of the story.
The devil said you shall not surely die.
If you eat of it, you will be like God.
Knowing good from evil.
And what did they do?
They listened to the devil.
Why?
Maybe because they wanted to be like God.
So they took the fruit. They ate
it and they did die, as God said.
They died spiritually, because they
couldn't have a relationship with God
anymore because sin entered them.
Now they had knowledge of evil.
And God is Holy.
He cannot have a relationship
with you if you live in darkness.
If you are evil.
So they died spiritually and we know
John 4:24 says God is Spirit and you
can only worship Him in Spirit and truth.
So they died spiritually and they brought
it on all humankind who were born from them.
They knew now the knowledge of good and also
the knowledge of evil and, according to some,
the seven sacred sciences are also connected to
the secret society of Freemasons we have today.
And the Illuminati, those who rebelled against
God, used the knowledge for evil and also with the
fallen angels who gave them certain information.
They used all of that for evil, which
includes mysticism and secret rituals.
According to the book The Spirit
of Freemasonry, Freemasonry was not
based on just normal architecture but
rather on religious and moral tenets.
I believe that those people who rebelled against
God after the flood did so in exactly the same
way that the people did before the flood
using the same knowledge to start evil
religions and occultic practices, worshiping
fallen angels, demons and nephilim as gods.
With this game, sorcery, mysticism,
evil rituals, and so much more.
And that is probably why this happened in Verse 5.
[Genesis 11:5-6]
So God saw where this was leading them towards...
an evil world exactly the same as the pre-flood
world, so He came down to stop it yet again
because of their prideful hearts, now building the
tower, because they wanted to rebel against God.
They want to ascend into heaven following the
false teachings of fallen angels doing these
ancient, perverted crafts, evil rituals,
mysticism, starting these religions of
these fallen angels pretending to be gods.
The Nelson's Bible dictionary says the tower was
created as a symbol for human pride and rebellion
I believe they could have built this tower in
rebellion against God, against the heavens,
to follow now again this pantheistic religion
of the nephilim and the fallen angels.
Now of course, a lot of
this has to do with Nimrod.
Who many say that the Epic of
Gilgamesh, you know, from Babylon.
The Babylonian Epic of Gilgamesh,
if you don't know about it search
it - many say that this is actually about Nimrod.
Gary Wayne says in his book The Genesis 6
Conspiracy all this took place at a time when
a dictator - Nimrod - had usurped absolute control
by force establishing the first empire of the new
epoch with Babel as its first united project.
Nimrod ignited a conspiracy modeled after the
Genesis 6 Conspiracy which had constructed the
Egyptian pyramids and the Sumerian ziggurats
as memorials and a legacy to their
spurious antediluvian accomplishments.
Now, this is actually a great book to read.
And I won't say that I agree with everything in it
as I said before.
I trust the Bible
100 percent - everything else you have
to read with goggles through the Bible.
Don't just trust everything you read.
But also don't throw the baby away
with the bath water.
This is very important.
Now I think that the idea of Nimrod - it
could have been that he wanted to unite
the whole world under one world government
where he is the leader using one religion.
Of course, all the information
given to him by Satan himself,
and his fallen angels, given to
him by someone called Hermes.
And I believe all of this happened for one
reason - and that is to rebel against God.
To lead people away from Him as the devil has
always tried to do with world governments and
certain people who want to control the world.
It is also interesting that the Freemasons call
Nimrod the first Grand Master after the flood.
You see, God knew that the world was sliding
into evil again. Rebellion - violence - sexual
sin and debauchery - all under the disguise of
a promised new world - does this not sound
familiar to the world that we live in now?
If you just open your eyes
and see what's going on?
It's the same thing repeating itself.
Before the flood, after the flood.
If you look in history and until this
period we are now closer than ever.
There are still secret societies and I won't
go in detail here because then it will take
my video off of YouTube, but there are secret
societies who still want one world, one religion,
one government, where they control what
you think and believe and how you live.
When Nimrod did this and God saw where this was
heading with the Tower of Babel, he stopped it.
[Genesis 11:6]
I believe that this is talking
about all the evil acts.
I mean, with the new movie that
just came out, The Sound of Freedom,
it opened people's eyes to just the
trafficking that's going on around them.
Millions of people.
It's a 150 billion dollar industry.
That's just part of the evil
that's going on in the world.
There is a lot more that is part of the
reason why God stopped it even back then.
To stop all the evil.
[Genesis 11:7-9]
Now Josephus, the Jewish historian,
he wrote something interesting.
He said that they built a tower so
that they can find shelter in case
God wanted to flood the world again, which
we of course know He wouldn't have done.
He still won't do it today
because that is His promise.
You still see it today - the rainbow - the rainbow
is the sign that He won't flood the Earth again.
And today a rainbow is even used for
something else - the LGBTQ community.
Actually the original design
they used had eight colors.
The one they use now it's got only six colors, but
God's rainbow has seven colors so you can fully
enjoy it when you see it in nature after the rain.
Now according to Josephus, the second reason
why they built the Tower of Babel was so that
Nimrod could ascend into heaven and kill God.
As crazy as it seems, that's one of the reasons.
So that he can avenge himself and the people.
And the people of the pre-flood world.
He wanted to slay the God who had caused the great
flood of Noah's time, just in case God decided
to judge the earth again with another flood.
You know, you will hear different stories
about that time from different cultures.
About the time of the flood and also
after it, it might have different names,
but it's the same people and you will start to see
a common thread of truth through all the stories.
Because it is the same people
and the same things that happen.
Even the Hebrew legends tell how Nimrod
even staged events where he shot arrows
into heaven in an attempt to slay God.
An Aztec legend, says that Teotihuacan, a
famous ziggurat, was built by giants
to transform men into gods and another
legend said the ziggurat built by giant
men resulted in the dispersal of humankind.
Remember, there were nephilim at this
time as I explained in the previous video.
And this ziggurat sounds like the Tower of Babel.
Now Adam and Eve could have gained a lot
of knowledge from God in the time
they walked with Him in the garden.
Knowledge God gave them about Himself.
Humans and the world which they probably
shared with their children.
But humans could have perverted
this knowledge if they rebel against God.
If they follow their own sinful flesh now
and use this knowledge for evil.
There's just a lot of things that can go worse,
especially with the fallen angels or demons
giving them more information to pervert this
knowledge even further.
And this is nothing
new and it will continue to happen.
People will follow the teachings of demons.
[1 Timothy 4:1]
But now let's go deeper.
Let's go back.
Some say that Adam told this to his children
- his line of children especially also the
line of Seth to Noah and Noah after
the flood taught it to his children.
They say the evil knowledge spread from Cain
to his descendants like Lamech the evil.
Remember the Bible says before the flood
that people only thought evil continually.
They followed evil.
They did evil.
It was a time where the nephilim were there.
The fallen angels.
It was just a soup of evil -
practicing occultic rituals,
committing murder, raping, stealing,
sexual sins, and the list just goes on.
Now, this super evil time probably happened in
the time right after the fallen angels came to
earth and created the half breeds, the nephilim,
because right in the next verse, it says this:
[ Genesis 6:5]
Some of these sources say that the evil Lamech
from Cain's side wrote all this ancient perverted
sciences on two pillars, so that the people
after the flood could still get this information.
And that it could guide them.
The one pillar was made of lateritic - some
type of brick so it won't sink - and the
other made of marble, so that it won't burn.
Supposedly the first pillar - the one
made out of lateritic - had the seven
sacred corrupted sciences inscribed on it.
The second pillar of marble contained the
directions to the location
of the nine vaults of Enoch.
Some say that it was buried
at the foot of the pyramids.
You know, they have a lot of interesting
documentaries on the pyramids and they
will tell you what they want you to know.
They'll make it interesting so that you
would wonder as well but they will
never really tell you the truth.
But that's a video for another time.
According to the craft legends (Freemasons):
So again some say that the pure
sacred knowledge came from Adam,
Seth and then up to Noah and his children.
Others say that the the corrupted evil sacred
sciences came from Cain and then to Lamech, the
evil Lamech and his children and that's where all
the evil sin came from before the world and spread
until God washed it all away with the flood.
Now, the Bible doesn't mention this
but the Bible does mention something
very interesting about the evil Lamech's
children who had interesting knowledge.
It mentions their names and
also what they were able to do
but why .... why only Lemach's children?
I mean, even if you look at Adam's side,
it does not mention any detail of Adam and
Eve's other children, but only the line of
the third child - Seth - where Noah came from.
Now, as you remember in the beginning of the
video, I read you 2 Timothy 3:16 that says that
the Word of God was inspired by God, right?
Written by humans but through
the power of the Holy Spirit.
So it is perfect, you can trust it and
everything in it is true and important.
So it is important - it was important
for God to include the evil Lamech,
the names of his children and what they could do.
[Genesis 4:19-20]
Now remember, even with music
you can use music for evil.
Even in rituals or you can use it for good.
[Genesis 4:22]
There's a lot of instruments that
you can make with bronze and iron.
The sister of Tubal-Cain was Naamah.
Now let me just remind you other
writings say that this is where the fallen
angels came down with these family lineages,
especially in the time of Lamech and his children
and created the nephilim and taught them these
perverted sciences so that they could use it
for evil and bring evil over the whole world
and according to them this is where evil
started to spread around the world - in the
pre-flood world - and where the pantheistic
religion started to worship fallen angels
pretending to be gods.
And this can be true.
It could have been in this time because even
in the time of Seth they still worshiped God.
Many, many of the children of
Adam and Eve still worship God.
The Bible says this - other sources
say this - and even the Freemasons.
According to Dr. Oliver who wrote the
book called Antiquities of Freemasonry:
Huh..
So a group
of people - the tribe Seth - his people - his
children - who were called the Sons of Light.
Sounds interesting.
The Bible also says:
[Genesis 4:25]
So Seth had Enosh and they worshiped God.
But even later at Enoch's time,
they still worship God.
This is the good Enoch,
not the evil one from the the line of Cain.
It might be a bit confusing here and there
because there are two names in the lineages
of Seth and of Cain that are similar.
The names Enoch and Lamech.
Now Adam had Seth - he had Enosh, who had Keenan,
then Mahalalel, then Jared, and then Enoch.
The seventh generation, who still worshiped
God and the flood came at the tenth generation.
So, at the seventh generation they worshiped God.
At the tenth generation there was the
flood, so they suddenly became evil.
The whole world apart from Noah.
Do you understand this?
Just in those few generations.
Now, how did this happen?
While the Bible doesn't say this, so I
can't say that this is 100 percent for sure,
but other ancient writings do.
Like Josephus and the Apocrypha.
Books that became evil because of the
fallen angels, also called watchers with
the leader called Azazel, and their mixed breed
offspring who people started to worship as God.
Especially the humans from the line of Cain.
So everything I'm telling you now comes from
all these other ancient writings and they
say that these fallen angels taught humans
the evil sacred sciences corrupting the good
sciences and also teaching them just other
evil things like the seventh science astronomy
which led to astrology and was used for evil.
Now, just very quick, if you think astrology
is not evil, if you believe in your star sign,
and that your future is determined
by certain stars or what month
you're born, please watch my video on this.
I'll link for you in the video description just
so you can have an idea of why this is evil.
So let me just back up a little bit - so
there was a pure branch of good
knowledge and then an evil one.
A perverted one, with the
help of the fallen angels.
Adam learned things directly
from God In the Garden of Eden.
Then he had Cain and Abel which
he probably taught many things.
For example, both of them knew how to farm.
Cain with plants and Abel with animals.
But Cain killed Abel and went east with all his
knowledge and he started cities being a mason,
having not only knowledge in
farming but also architecture.
So after Cain, Adam and Eve had Seth
and then many other sons and daughters.
The Bible doesn't say exactly how many.
I'll tell you what Josephus says in just a second
but they probably taught all that they knew.
Part of that - some of these interesting
sciences - that and other things
that they learned from God.
And they probably taught them to use it for good.
Now, Joseph the Jewish historian wrote that
Adam and Eve had 33 sons and 23 daughters.
Now again the Bible doesn't say how many kids
they have but this could have been true.
So let's just focus on Seth now and Cain.
So Cain went to east with all the knowledge.
He and his descendants used it for evil.
Seth, he lived righteously and used the knowledge
for good. According to the Apocrypha books,
Josephus and other writings - Cain's
descendants - used all the knowledge,
perverted it with the help of the fallen angels,
and they did rituals and a lot of evil things,
until it was so bad that God had to stop it.
But before the flood came they supposedly wrote
their seven sacred sciences that's perverted
on pillars and hieroglyphics so that the people
after the flood can continue these evil
deeds that came from the fallen angels.
After the flood the devil was still
there, and demons as they still are today.
So they started to go to work - working on
people's fleshly sinful natures to get them
to turn from God again, and to follow the
perverted knowledge and worship false gods.
Alright, now I'm gonna go deeper.
Now it's gonna get interesting.
So wake up - refresh - refocus.
Here we go.
Now, most of this comes
from other ancient writing.
So I'm not sure how much of this is
true but a lot of it could be true.
After the flood a man called Hermes -
will also later be called Toth - the
new Egyptian god of wisdom went with Ham
- Noah's son - to Egypt and found it.
The ancient perverted knowledge.
Hermes decoded the hieroglyphics
and gave the information to Nimrod which
is why Egypt built their empire so quickly.
Especially with the knowledge
of how to use hieroglyphics
and this is why Nimrod was also so powerful.
Now some writers say that Abraham
told the Egyptians astrology.
Josephus also says that Abraham taught them the
signs of arithmetic and astronomy and another
writer called Eupolemus actually says Abraham
invented astrology before he went to Egypt
which I of course don't believe.
Even Philo claimed Abraham studied
astronomy and mathematics.
Could they be right?
Well, I'm not sure.
Abraham probably was
well-educated because of his family line so
there's a lot of things that he could have known.
Remember, Abraham came from Shem and Shem had
our Arphaxad and Abraham came only 292 years
after our Arphaxad so Shem was still alive
because he lived 400 years after the flood.
So he could have learned a lot of things
from his family line even from Shem.
Abraham or Abram as he was called back
then - before God called him - I mean he
was an important - he was a very important figure
especially today for Christians, Muslims and Jews.
But a lot of people forget that he
did not worship God in the beginning.
[Joshua 24: 2]
Yeah, they served other gods.
Abraham used to live in the ancient city of
Ur of the Galdeans which was in modern Iraq.
The great ziggurat of Ur was built by
Ur Namu around 2100 before Christ.
And was dedicated to Nanna the moon god.
Remember this was the same pantheistic
religion of worshiping the demons.
I talked about the moon
goddess in the previous video.
It is the same pantheistic religion
where they worship fallen angels.
They did that before the flood.
Now remember in Genesis 12.
Abraham was around 75 years
old when God called him.
[Genesis 12:1-2]
Now it is likely that Abraham could have
had knowledge of Yahweh passed down from
family to family but a lot of them started
to worship other gods - the moon goddess and
the other gods we talked about in the previous
videos - but then something amazing happened.
Yahweh.
God called Abraham directly
and then he followed God.
Abraham actually called Him the most high God.
[Genesis 14:22]
So Abram and his family started to follow God.
Yahweh.
But remember most of the other nations
still follow these other fake Gods which
is part of the perverted sacred
knowledge or ancient knowledge.
According to Gary Wayne.
From Egypt, the new religious
cloak draped over the corrupted sciences was
transferred to the Greeks and Romans and to
many other pagan nations of the Mediterranean.
Most of the religious beliefs spread through
Nimrod and Hermes who became a
priest and to some even a god.
Now remember a few minutes ago I told you that
Hermes will also be called Toth, the Egyptian god.
It is the same thing, just different names
with different cultures as time went on.
Hermes is also the name of the Greek
god of interpretive communication.
They started the old religion that
was there before the flood again
after the flood with Osiris and Isis used
as the model for the other pagan nations.
Osiris was the best known.
The Greeks called him Bacchus.
The Muchans of Asia Minor
called him Panuses or Apollo.
The Indians named him Dionysus.
The Romans called him Liber
and the Arabians, Adonis.
It was the same mystic religions
found in the same sun god allegories.
Now let me get to the point here.
We know that God is the only God.
He is the true light.
The devil is not a god at all - he's just a
fallen angel - and the weaker angels below
him - they're just angels.
They're not gods.
They have power but they're not God.
But Lucifer is jealous,
and he wants to ascend himself above God.
He wants people to think of him as God.
So he is trying to show people that he is the
light and in this world, what is the light?
The symbol of light that we see - the sun -
so all these different names - these different
gods looking at the sun - I'm gonna get to
the point a little bit later on but first:
[2 Corinthians 11:14]
Now the sun has always been
used as the symbol of light.
Light and knowledge, that is
what the sun was mostly used for.
So these gods are all sun god
allegories of Satan himself.
Who came to give human beings knowledge.
It started back with Adam and Eve in the garden,
where he wanted them to eat of the fruit
so that they can get the knowledge of evil.
So the devil's plan was to bring the knowledge
of evil into the world through Adam and Eve and
that's what he did and it is the same God
that the Freemasons still worship today.
Just look at the one dollar bill - on the top of
the pyramid at the 33rd level of masonry those
who reach it - who are deemed worthy receive
the final and biggest reward of information.
When you look at that pyramid
picture you see the sun there.
All the 33 levels - the sun illuminates it.
Shining its light and wisdom,
the knowledge to them.
Illuminating all ... all the sun allegories.
All of it points to who?
Satan.
Now there is so much here that you still need to
find out and to go and research to learn yourself.
And then you will realize how many politicians
- corporations - the banking system - most of
the entertainment industry - and even
power positions are part of this.
And it stretches back to Nimrod
who wanted to control the world
and back to the antediluvian period.
All of the strange things you've heard
like the secret societies of the Knights
Templar, the Freemasons and all the others.
It is just the tip of the iceberg.
Now I've just given you a little
bit of a summary in a little bit of history of
what could have happened and where we are now.
Where we are now in his last 300 years,
there is actually a lot of information.
But if you want to know more
about this, then please let
me know in the comment section down below.
And I'll go into this a little bit deeper.
This video has already been too long and they
say the average attention span of a human today
is only 8.25 seconds, so in Part Seven of this
series, we're going further with the series of
10 life-changing truths every man must know.
Now what are we going to talk about?
Well, you will have to wait and see.
But I'm gonna tell you this now, as you've
seen it in all the other parts of this series
- it's going to be a very interesting video.
So subscribe if you don't want
to miss that video and remember
that life is short, so don't waste yours.
Cheers guys.